عندما بدات تمرد يفكيني بالهجين قائد قوات
فاغنر قبل نحو شهرين بعد ان اتهم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بزرع الغام في طريق مقاتله
سارعت وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه الى
اطلاق تصريحات مثيره تنبات فيها بانتقام
الرئيس بوتين منه واكدت ان تمرد هو الهجوم
الاكثر مباشره على الدوله الروسيه وان
بوتين ينتظر محاولا كسب المزيد من الوقت
وانه يفكر فيما يجب فعله مع فاغنر وقائدها
بريدجين فهل ينتقم بوتين فعليا من اي شخص
يعارضه الباحث السياسي نشر مقالا في مجله
اتلانتك الامريكيه قال فيها ان مصرع
بريكوجين على اثر سقوط طائرته في مدينه
تفير ليس سوى اعدام ميداني نفذه لقائد
قوات فاغمر لافتا الى ان بوتين سبق ان امر
بقتل مقربين فعلوا اقل مما فعله بريكوجين
عندما اعلن تمرده الغريب بحسب نيكوز ان
سقوط الطائره تزامن وخطوه الروسيه اعفت
سيلفي سورفيكين قائد القوات الجويه
الروسيه من منصبه وكان اختفى عن الانظار
منذ تمرد قائد قوات فاغنر ورجح مسؤولون
امريكيون انه على علم مسبق بالتمرد
ميخائيل
احد ملوك تجاره النفط في روسيا عرف
بمعارضته الشديده للرئيس بوتين ومكث عشره
اعوام في السجن في سيبيريا بتهمه الاحتيال
قبل ان يخرج بعفو وينتقل للعيش في سويسرا
يقول
ان تاريخ موت معارضي هذا نظام مثير
للاعجاب مكثت في السجن 10 سنوات وكان من
الممكن ان اتعرض للقتل في اي يوم بسهوله
اليكسي نافالني ايضا من اشد معارض بوتين
ومنتقده
وحاول الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه لكنه
منع بسبب ادانات سابقه وهو ما نفاه
المعارض مؤكدا ان مشكلاته القانونيه كانت
انتقاما من الكرملين نفى لسبق ان اصيب
بحروق كيميائيه خطيره في عينيه وصمم في
اثناء وجوده في طائره متوجهه الى موسكو
[موسيقى]